hey what is up guys mkbhd here and i
have the samsung galaxy s4 in hand now
along with the htc one and the galaxy s4
it's a great phone and all but what i
wanted to figure out at least what i was
most concerned about when i first got it
was
you know it's it's just a small sort of
evolutionary update to the galaxy s3
it's more incremental uh you could say
evolutionary rather than revolutionary
so my biggest concern was why did they
keep the same design going on are they
kind of going the sort of tick-tock
strategy that we've seen apple do with
the iphone 4 then 4s then 5 and now 5s
is that what samsung's doing right now
that's what i wanted to know so samsung
brought me to new york to check out the
galaxy s4 the us variants and a whole
bunch of other stuff they had a whole
samsung experience shop set up so in
those experience shops they had a whole
bunch of different devices you can go
around and play with the different
devices and experiences they had a whole
bunch of people waiting in line to get
in and once you got in there were
devices like the galaxy note 8.0 the
galaxy camera the galaxy s4 note 2 a
whole bunch of other samsung products
like laptops and cases and accessories
and things like that it was just full of
samsung products so that was pretty neat
that they showed us around that but also
at the same event i was able to get a
hold of and actually interview samsung's
ryan biden so he's the director of
product marketing for samsung he's
basically the reason why you've heard of
the galaxy s4 he's a big part of why it
was such a successful product you might
even remember him from the uh the
broadway sort of presentation of the
galaxy s4 remember him this guy remember
that guy yeah that's ryan biden so i was
actually there with a couple of other
youtubers including austin from duncan
33303 and soldier knows best but austin
interviewed ryan first and he asked
pretty much the best set of questions
possible and you'll probably see that
content on his channel soon enough but
he asked basically the exact set of
questions that i was going to ask so i
just kind of stood up next to him and
basically winged it so without any
further ado i'll go ahead and show you
exactly what happened we played a bit of
a word association game with samsung and
this is the result all right so i'm
going to say a couple of words and you
can just tell me the first word or words
that come to your mind when i say that
okay all right i'll start off easy
galaxy uh obviously the galaxy s4 okay
um samsung
galaxy s4 okay um features
uh so there's a few things that come to
my mind when you say features um
because you've already prompted me to
say galaxy s4 it would be features in
the galaxy s4 so things like air view
and air gestures
uh watch on for tv remote control maybe
some of the great features of 13
megapixel camera okay
um
quality
quality
um so there makes me think about
materials and build decisions and
technology trade-offs so
for example with the galaxy s4
one of the things that some people kind
of compare is why have we chosen to go
polycarbonate versus aluminum or
something like that
and it's not a quality decision because
those materials are as good as anything
else it's about making a device that's
thin and light so wanting to make sure
that you've got removable battery
expandable storage and lots of great
stuff so high quality device but still
pretty flexible
sweet
um
see i'm out of words already
uh let's go with
versatile
versatile what word comes from i want to
say bristol besides the galaxy s4 oh
besides galaxy s4 when you say versatile
i think of the range of samsung
smartphones and devices i mean basically
we've got devices at all price points
for all people
and you know this interview is pretty
versatile too so
okay uh i saw a tweet like three weeks
ago that just had a list of all the
screen sizes of samsung devices it went
from like 2.8 to i think 10.1 yeah um
you guys have 10 inch tablets and you
have
4.8 inch or 5 inch now galaxy s4 what's
your favorite tablet screen size and why
that's a great question so i actually
prefer the 10.1s i tend to prefer larger
tablets um because i generally roll with
both a phone and a tab um
basically using something like galaxy s3
or galaxy s4 with 4.8 or 5 inches that's
a pretty big screen on the phone so got
big screen still really portable so then
the next thing piece for me is i want to
make sure that i've got enough
additional real estate to make it
worthwhile carrying that extra device so
that's why 10.1 is the tab size for me
makes sense
all right that's been it thank you so
either way that's basically it i figured
i would share that little quick fun
tidbit with you guys and give it a
thumbs up if you enjoyed it uh but now
that that has happened and i have the
galaxy s4 and the htc one in hand let
the mkbhd coverage and comparisons and
reviews begin so thumbs up if you're
ready for that either way thank you for
watching and i'll talk to you guys very
soon with that coming up next
peace
you